[Music]
what's up everybody Welcome to LED live
we got an exciting show we have a guest
named Wendy from Indiana and she's going
to be presenting to us some deception in
children's cartoons nothing new to us
right all about this so thank you for
bringing some new stuff that we actually
haven't covered because I've recently
seen uh some of these new episodes of
Bluey and things like that it seems like
a pretty wholesome cartoon but you've
been seeing it with your children and
and some red flags came up yeah so I
have two little boys and we often go to
the library and rep movies as a treat
for them and um just watching the shows
and they are they're super cute my boys
love them but as we start watching I
start getting red flags you know I start
seeing some things that disturb me don't
necessarily go along with my belief
system and so you know I have to watch
that with some discernment and see what
is worth putting in front of my kids and
what's not so I started Gathering all
those together and um eventually if I
like there's enough here I feel like we
really got to say something about this
so this first clip I just wanted to say
I included to show you how cute it is it
does have a lot of parent interaction
which is great um and it shows the kids
just really loving their time with their
parents so this is to show you how
adorable Bluey can be ladies and
gentlemen I will now play for you the
Rondo
[Music]
alaturka
hi ladies and gentlemen I'm terribly
sorry I seem to be having a little bit
of trouble with
my dad I want to be in the piano no it's
still my turn taking turns can be
difficult dad she's had this many times
you can be the bum bong
ghost
[Music]
so to me that was wholesome you know
like that's like a beautiful picture of
a dad playing with his kids and and even
when the other one was kind of jealous
the dad was like no you guys can both
come and play you know yeah taking turns
things that you would want kids to think
about and discuss with their parents I
love the artwork like I started seeing
these before I ever saw the show at
Walmart I just saw a collection of the
toys and I was like man I love that it
looks so cute yeah they have toys with
Bluey oh yeah oh so it's a big thing oh
yeah it's real big this is actually on
Disney plus it's not a Disney show it's
from Australia but Disney always loves
to buy up anything even like Baby
Einstein and stuff like that yeah but
you know I think artwork is a big draw
like probably like 50% of why people
watch something sponge Bob it's got
amazing art those stories are not you
know it's got some humor in it but I
think there's something that draws us to
Art my boys yeah they're they're very
much drawn to Bluey and when we first
started watching this episode they were
even you know hey do the piano on us and
and wanting to be a part of what they're
seeing and so we still do that with them
because it's it's actually help parents
think of some fun things that yeah I
mean it does it helps parents see this
is a good way to interact with their
children don't forget to have
imagination there's a lot of great
things that parents can draw from this
um so good feedback good things in the
media about it and all that yeah yeah
except for the cancel culture article I
saw it said there's an article that said
cancel culture is coming for Bluey why
there was some lady she was saying
where's the racial diversity I'm like
dude they dogs that are like blue and
brown and there every there's definitely
racial diversity that is so weird and
then she said what about U you know
disabilities which I think is cool to
include somebody in a wheelchair or
something but then it it always comes
back to the the gender sexual relation
thing you know it's like if you don't
include this very small minority of the
population in every kids show then it
must be canell and we see that happening
uh pretty much in all children's media
yeah sadly yeah well so here this next
clip will show you how um some of the
bluey kind of takes a turn and so you
have the cuteness still but they start
putting in some other agendas so we'll
start seeing what that like don't worry
bumpy the wise our wolf hound will be
able to Magic you
[Music]
better he's a Trixie oh why a wolf H
bumpy is sick oh poor little fell it's
not fair please can you help him I am
not a puppy doctor please can you magic
him better magic please please please
please okay little one perhaps there is
a way I can help oh wonderful bring me a
pair of purple Underpants okay a now
it's making sense wao I'm not finished I
need a pair of purple underpants from
someone who's never been sick never been
sick never been sick oh have you ever
been sick
oh yes I had a runny nose last year well
it will have to be someone else's purple
Underpants I'm afraid my problems I'll
get some from someone in town we'll be
right back good luck baracus so that
Underpants thing was interesting yeah
why it have to be Underpants exactly
like that was so Random like you could
say any object but then there's an
Underpants and then this dog is
literally like okay I mean obviously we
don't see any Genia but that is clearly
he's naked
right in front of him I think if you
told somebody hey I got this idea for a
kids show where you know this little kid
goes to an adult adult says hey give me
your Underpants and the dog takes it off
it's a little alarming uh but right but
when it's dogs what's the context to
this like why why are the Underpants so
important honestly it could have been
anything she's right the the point of
the show this episode is showing that um
everybody's the same and the fact that
everyone gets sick so the younger dog
Bingo is sick in the hospital and her
dad and Bluey are making like a homemade
show with all their family and they're
getting together to say Hey you know
everyone gets sick don't worry about it
just wait it out it'll go away wow but
then of course we also have yeah the
Underpants completely unnecessary I
actually didn't even think of that the
first time I was getting this clip I was
more focused on you know who she goes to
see right the new age Guru who has all
the answers exactly what you don't see
in this little clip is beforehand she
asks everyone she knows what should I do
where should I go and then finally
someone tells her oh go see the wise old
Wolfhound and so then she goes and you
see you know the Psychedelic colors and
the crystals and people are just like oh
that's that's awesome but if that would
have been like go talk to the pastor and
he went to the youth pastor and the
pastor gave him good advice people like
don't be shoving your beliefs down my or
like oh that's boring you know when I
was younger I was really involved in
Harry Potter um my parents took me to
the library as well but not to watch
whome kids shows I wasn't raised a
Christian we would read a lot Harry
Potter books we started watching the
movies and everything and and you know I
I even had the Harry Potter video games
and I wanted to cast the Spells I
remembered what the Spells were called
from the video game and I was mentioning
it and I was like oh this is so cool and
I want to be like Z and so your media
had an influence on you absolutely
couldn't have okay absolutely it did on
me too the movie The Craft I didn't get
into Harry Potter I don't even know if
Harry Potter was around when I was a kid
but uh wait you're that much older than
me that much older
when I was in high school was a movie
called The Craft the first one that came
out they've rebooted it for this
generation to be tainted by it too but
um yeah you know four High School
hotties practicing Witchcraft and it it
looked a lot more realistic than Harry
Potter right Harry Potter is like a wand
and all this stuff but they would just
it it was real witchcraft that they were
doing um they were sitting in circles
and doing binding spells and trying to
make a guy fall in love with them and
all these things that any teenager would
want to have that power to do so
definitely I was like yeah that looks
way cooler than Christianity people
might think those shows are a lot more
overt than let's say a cartoon but the
mind is so powerful and the it it it
takes on the principles that he that it
sees and you kind of it comes back to
your mind at the oddest times but I was
watching this clip and it's like a child
could think oh if the magic doesn't work
the first time or if I ask and I don't
get it the first time I should keep
asking and keep asking and then and then
it will something will manifest or what
have you usually when people for the
first time either try uh tarot cards or
palm reading and it doesn't really work
out they say oh this was a fluke and
they move on but if they have that
message of maybe I should try it again
maybe I should ask again another time
and then do whatever the guru tells me
so I can get the outcome that I desire
it's like teaching the persistence like
exactly trying exactly which is also a
principle we have in Christianity of
like um going to the Lord and and
putting your your requests before him
pray without ceasing but it just goes to
like which door do you want to open do
you want a god of blessing or do you
want Satan who has no good intention
towards you yeah and the other thing is
that um people might saying oh but this
is just innocent but like you can see
how from a very young age kids are
taught that spiritualism is good right
that Spirits are good they're your
friend and then you know you get into
movies like Harry Potter when you a
little bit older and now they're cool
they're cool kids you know and maybe
somebody Associates with Harry Potter CU
they're the nerd they're under dog but
they can be the hero and through magic
and you know like eventually when you
come to your teen years and maybe your
brain cells are still developing and
somebody invites you to a seance or like
a play with a Ouija board you're going
to do it and you know like because
you've been trained the Bible the Bible
says train up a child in the way he
should go and when he's old you will not
depart from it which obviously speaks of
teaching in the way of the Bible but I
do believe the opposite happens as well
only by gra of God can a person when
they are an adult who's had such a
childhood still come to the Lord but
they are set up in a certain direction
yeah this this kind of like a
misunderstanding I don't know if it's
misunderstanding but people think that
the world is just neutral like oh if you
didn't have the Bible then you're just
going to grow up in this neutral thing
but there is an agenda like you see uh
the new age being pushed in the The Lion
King that dude with Rafiki he was the
wise one that did all that Voodoo and
New Age stuff and then uh you talking
about spiritualism that's in all the
Disney movies they always talk to even
in the L King he talked to his dead dad
Pocahontas talking to Mother Willow and
there's all the you know the spirits of
the Dead Mulan talking to the dead so
you have necromancy in most of Disney uh
the new age being pushed from the 90s I
mean even the 80s and stuff but like
Tiny Tunes that duck she was always
meditating um Boy Meets World the the
girl that all the boys like she was a
new age so there it's not a neutral it's
not like there's a neutral message it's
usually a push towards Witchcraft and
like KY was saying there's a lot more
overt stuff like Harry Potter and the
craft but Satan has a tackle box he's
like oh you don't oh the parents don't
want him to watch Harry Potter what
about bluee hey Absolutely I'll get you
this way and my son is two and he loves
blue as soon as the theme song comes on
he's like BL and we really don't we've
watched it a couple times but he's he
already knows you know that's the sound
and starts dancing and then he wants to
do the magic xylophone all the time and
yeah so going back to the Underpants
like obviously we get the message right
but I don't think the end justifies the
means especially the world that we live
in today we uh we talk a lot about
what's happening online what's posted
online all the sensitive content that's
put out that kids get a hold of and it's
through their phones it's through their
devices and so the image of a child I'm
sure it was for a comedic effect uh the
the child the puppy is in the hospital
watching on their phone their family
reenacting this thing but then
Underpants is involved in a comedic way
of like giving your underpants to
someone else and just switch the context
like a friend hands them a phone and
it's the same type of thing but it's in
a very inappropriate way of like a
stranger with a child or what have you
but that's comedy you know that's funny
oh I've seen that before in Bluey like
so desensitizing exactly desensitizing
and then also so making the warning not
as potent cuz it's like oh but it
happens here so why can't it be good
here that's a Hollywood trick too put a
laugh track on and it's okay you know
it's been happening through history we
we have h a video on our Channel um
where it shows how Nick lonan is selling
explicit content to children and we'll
put a little box in the top of the
corner here so you can click on it but
you should definitely go watch that yeah
yeah absolutely okay well we'll keep
rolling and see how some of these
deceptions are still in the cartoon
fing why did anyone answer
me sh up I
said where could they all be okay I need
to figure this
[Music]
[Laughter]
out 2 3
4 oh yeah that's
right than
you than
you
[Music]
you oh man I had a Christmas tree stuck
in my back the whole
time can you believe I got distracted
and forgot we were playing hide and seek
yes very
believable wow that was just super
blatant like it was the dog version of
Buddha and the bluey I guess is getting
distracted they're playing a game Hide
and Seek getting distracted like what
was I doing instead of praying and
asking God bring back to my memory what
I was doing uh let's just look at Buddha
and get in the meditative pose and my
whole mind gets emptied the whiteness
everywhere and it gets brought back you
know again this isn't is n't a neutral
thing this is teaching Eastern mysticism
and if that would have been bie prays to
Jesus and ask for what was I doing to
come back there'd be an uproar like why
are you putting this in my kids cartoons
I don't I don't teach them Christianity
yeah anytime you see Christianity in the
media it's always mocked and ridiculed
like on The Simpsons you got the
annoying neighbor he's the Christian but
when this new age oh it's cool hip and
trendy and yeah it's crazy we have a
good friend of the ministry and of the
show called Eric Wilson he's been on the
many shows here before in LED live and
uh he was formerly in uh martial arts
and he had black belts and multiple ones
and then beyond that where he was
trained to be a disciple which is beyond
the black belt um and we did a
documentary with him years ago called
the dragon revealed which he shares his
testimony part one and part two he kind
of goes over the problems with martial
arts and E mysticism and all these
practices including yoga including
meditation and he explains it as and
this was his own experience being way up
there he explains it as the whole goal
of all of this is to achieve the chi
power Chi which you see in all these
magazines and everything he said she is
nothing else than demon possession
that's why they're able to levitate
that's why they're able to cut through
blocks of ice Etc and so he's saying
like you cannot disconnect the spiritual
from the physical you cannot just be
like oh I'm just doing self-defense I'm
just meditating because I'm just you
know trying to Cle stressed out I'm
trying to clear my mind he says all of
that is engraved in this whole idea of
spiritualism and achieving the chi
wishes demon possession so if you want
to watch that documentary by the way
part one is for free on our YouTube
channel the dragon revealed and part two
and part one you can buy or rent on our
Vimeo Channel just look for vimeo.com
Light Studios yeah it's good too um one
of the reasons I quit teaching in public
school was for that very reason they
actually have now in in all schools
around the country what they do is
rebranding it from meditation to
mindfulness and so there's all this
research out that is proven when kids
spend 5 10 minutes in mindfulness every
day in the classroom it lowers bad
behavior and yeah they have higher
scores because they're more apt to
concentrate during the school day and um
the school that I was in we were
actually given you know yoga cards and a
little chime so every day they would
yeah they'd encourage us after recess if
they're Rowdy just go ahead and do the
chime and everybody can just calm their
mind and do these things yeah you know I
bet they could do a study that says uh
kids that were read the Psalms after
after a recess were calm and they had
higher test scores I mean this is crazy
because in public school system they
actually got rid of prayer and the Bible
and and now they're just introducing
something new a new religion because
when I was in high school after the
announcements they called it a moment of
silence so for like two minutes it just
a moment of silence and you could pray
if you wanted to but they're not going
to say that um but now they're bringing
new Eastern mysticism and New Age
meditation into the school and that's
okay I thought it was supposed to be
separation of church and state and
that's why we got rid of the Bible and
prayer but now we're bringing in the new
religion just tolerate everything but
Christianity that's right so something
want to add here is the fact that this
kid is uh coming up to this Buddha
statue and instantly gets what he wants
which is to find everybody in the
hideand-seek game and you know it that's
not taught in Christianity in
Christianity it's like yeah you pray to
the Lord and he says that he wants to
answer our prayers and he listens but
sometimes God not answering a prayer is
a way of him answering because sometimes
what we ask for is not good for us or it
might be coming from self selfish point
of view and God knows what's best and he
he answers according to what is best for
us cuz he loves us but that doesn't
always mean like there's you know
instant gratification God is not a
gumball machine kind of God where you
just put in your coin you get something
sweet out of it Genie whenever you want
like a genie yeah God is much more wise
than that and this case they're showing
this Buddha statue and it's showing
Eastern mysticism and religion and it's
like oh yeah the kids are taught oh if I
just come to Buddha I I just get
whatever I want immediately I'm not
going to come to the Christian God where
I might have to wait for something you
know yeah hear when you pray God either
says yes or no or wait
right that's right so next we're going
to just take a look at how um you know
we've seen a lot of the Eastern um
meditation and we've seen how they're
not obviously going to God they're going
to something else and what that opens
them up to so it's very brief you have
to listen closely but we're going to
take a really close look at kind of some
of the side effects of meditation the
bub so Sal oh well done Bingo hey what's
with all the salad sorry R it's okay Dad
are there aliens on the roof yeah
[Music]
maybe Mom can I be an astronaut when I
grow up if you
like
so yeah New Age meditation leads to even
bl's in a karate outfit since we you
just brought up the martial arts and we
know that there's a religious aspect to
martial arts even but yeah mentioning
are there aliens on the moon so now
you're putting that seed in kids' minds
too and the dad wasn't like no that's
ridiculous he was like no maybe yeah
yeah maybe yeah yeah it's interesting
because what you're seeing today more
and more is you know this tie to
religion and then UFOs or ufology and
how it's tied to the new age yeah and so
what I wish I would have brought I have
a book that I'd read and it it shows 10
different uh doctors that came together
and combined all their research and it
was just like a list of what possible
side effects you could have after
meditation and one of them surprisingly
was alien encounters wow I'm like that's
just a side effect like headache and
alien en counters so random but enough
that you know 10 different doctors got
together to publish this to say you know
obviously this is a deal so and they're
calling them aliens not like Spirit
guides or something else right wow you
got this cute innocent show that has all
these good values saying like showing
kids you should go to the guru you
should meditate and oh when you start
seeing aliens it's okay remember the dad
even said there's probably aliens out
there I me it's like Satan just setting
you up like yeah one little this and and
this is going to happen and we've
released plenty of videos on a YouTube
channel we've released a documentary
that all show that this whole alien
thing it's nothing else than just demon
possession AB or like demons coming in
the form of aliens uh presenting
themselves as a higher intelligence when
really it's just another Avenue for
Satan to deceive you you just blew
someone's mind just now
yeah go watch it go watch it it's all on
our Channel they're interdimensional
deceivers not Intergalactic Travelers
yeah absolutely so the next couple of
Clips I'm going to show you it's
actually a lady that's new age and she
kind of takes you they're short but she
takes you through her journey and how
she started with meditation and where it
took her and it really ties into this
episode with her saying are there aliens
on the moon so I thought it was
interesting one of the first things I
wanted to do when I got away from from
home was I wanted to take a Meditation
Retreat I wanted to go on this
Meditation Retreat so it was a 10day
silent meditation of tree called
Thea really cool out in the middle of
the wood W wanted to CER myself and on
the second night of meditation I ended
up getting abducted by these really tall
white looking beings and that just seems
normal I mean she seems excited to share
that when she meditated she got abducted
by aliens what's the purpose of these
Retreats is the silent Retreats is the
Retreats where you have on like these
blindfolds the whole time for extended
period of time and then when you lift
them off finally like it's just a SE
euphoric experience of now you're
getting light back like I haven't heard
of that but I've heard of like the
isolation Chambers and stuff yeah where
you have there's no sensus so you're in
the water and you don't feel anything
it's body temperature so you don't even
feel the water yeah you don't so you
don't feel anything there's no why
because you're you can't see anything
you're in a complete Black capsule you
don't feel anything because you're
floating in the salty water that's body
temperature so you don't even feel the
water you don't feel like you're sitting
on anything you're floating in space and
it causes hallucinogenic reactions and
stuff because like there's nothing to
distract your senses touch feel anything
um and then everything you think is just
kind of like visualized in front of you
and people literally come out of there
like their whole lives are changed it's
crazy yeah I would think for a lot of
people going into the new age it's
challenging to learn how to shut off the
distractions how to close your mind and
truly open yourself up to the point
where the deception can happen so a lot
of people that you know they
spend honestly like an admirable amount
of their time just in silence to reach
something you know it's almost like I
call the Christians like how much time
do we spend in God's word how much time
do we spend in prayer like they're
they're topping us here to get to the
aliens like come on we get to step up
our game but you know it's just I think
a step for them to then reach whatever
it is they're trying to contact or
Channel or okay these practices are a
slippery slope you know a lot of times
people say you know I just like we hear
all these new age stories and they're
like yeah I started out with yoga I had
a bad back and I was doing it for
stretching I just did it for exercise
and so I'm going to these yoga classes
and I and the either the yoga instructor
or somebody I go to the class with
starts saying hey have you ever tried
meditation is really good for stress and
all this oh well I'm stressed out so now
I'm doing meditation and next thing you
know I'm communicating with beings
ascended masters and a lot of times
there's aliens involved in these
ascended masters and then next thing you
know you're like Demi lado you're going
out to a a field and meditating and
you're seeing an apparition of a glowing
disc I actually just on YouTube um just
searching through stuff she has a video
where it says there were three aliens in
her room I had a night where I was
dreaming and I say dreaming very Loosely
because I don't really know what
happened but I all of a sudden was in my
room and and there was like three beings
and then and then they they were like do
you want to see your planet I like
whooshed out of my room and was like
hovering over the planet and then all of
a sudden they're like you want to see
our planet then I whooshed to this like
pink and purple planet that I've never
seen But and then and so that with the
hypnotherapy I was like trying to figure
out what exactly that was was it like I
don't want to use the word abduction
because that implies that it wasn't with
consent I was totally for it she crazy
in recent years became a professing
Christian was baptized in the Jordan
River and then less than two years later
she's channeling aliens and telling
other people they should do it too so
sad just shows how important choices are
how one thing can lead to the next can
lead to possession you know but it's
true in the opposite direction as well
like good having good choices creates
good habits it also puts you in in the
position to be hearing the voice of God
and um you know accept the gift of
Salvation it's it's all really boils
down to Choice yeah yeah absolutely so I
mean blue teaching you to meditate and
then they're kind of throwing that seed
of aliens are real even the dad thinks
they're probably real and now we see a
real life woman practicing meditation
and gets abducted so there is a
connection here yeah and then just okay
wait till you hear what she says about
the
moon I wonder where this meeting is
going to take place and so we start
traveling floating around all of a
sudden we're getting off this planet all
of a sudden we're floating out of the
atmosphere and like oh okay didn't
expect this all of a sudden we're going
to the moon and getting excited this is
great we're going to have a meeting with
the Galactic Federation on the moon
there must be some sort of Base there I
didn't know at this point turns out we
went to the moon but instead of going on
the moon to this meeting we actually
went inside the moon I don't know if any
of you knew that the moon was Hollow and
it's actually just the satellite device
yeah you cool um I didn't know at this
time that the moon was Hollow so we have
to travel inside the center wow so
aliens on the moon but I I'm going to
make a point here I don't believe that
she actually went to the moon I believe
that that
obviously demonic manifestations like
they can make you feel something show
you something um you know growing up I I
had some weird things sometimes when I
would see like weird stuff like I would
wake up and I would see like blue balls
and floating around and whatnot and and
um so like you know these things happen
but it doesn't mean that there was
actually a blue ball in my room it means
that were some weird demonic
manifestations you know you bring up an
interesting point
um Satan has power right but not the
same Power Authority that God has for
instance Satan cannot create and those
types of things but okay here's an
example of of of God interacting with
Humanity Philip was what transported
teleported from where he was to visit
the
Enoch the Enoch unic to visit the unic
or you have the case where Jesus when
the crowd turned turned against him or
was actually going to push him off the
cliff he disappeared and showed up
somewhere else so you know and we
believe these things like these things
actually happen so is it possible now
for the counter for the devil to to
teleport people in this way even if it's
not their physical body it's their
Consciousness and it's a real thing you
think absolutely yeah yeah when like
Lucifer is an angel like we we we think
like Satan is like a a counterpart to
God like there's God and there's the
devil no there's God and then there's
angels and Satan's one of those angels
but even the angels can give visions and
Lucifer is an angel Satan is an angel he
still has power he's still a very
powerful foe that we are we we're
matchless to him right without God's
word and if you are messing around tarot
cards meditation yoga all these things
you're playing on his territory you're
giving him an invitation into your life
and so now when you're seeking I want to
have an astral out-of- Body Experience
like I've heard about Satan's like all
right I'll give you one and now when
you're closing your eyes or even in your
sleep I talk about um lucid dreaming and
things like that Satan has now give has
been given permission to give you these
visions and he can make you fly out and
see things that are really there you're
seeking after it you're asking for it so
you know you're giving
permission okay well let's keep going I
think next we have another oh this is
something thing I found I thought it was
hilarious these are delicious have you
had them before I was actually at the
grocery store and I was like hey these
look good you know they look healthy and
I just flip it over to check out the
nutritional facts just check this out
what I know I don't remember that right
in the superet must the different
brand so yeah it's just talking you know
a lady she's meditating and she's having
these cravings and this wonderful
nutritious in her yoga studio you know
fresh fruit and water and then boom
missing snack displayed blame on Aliens
and saying that they came to to eat all
of her chips apparently wow it's
interesting they keep making the same
connection yeah like comical but still
like same bag they're meditation aliens
like if they weren't all these other
evidences of these things being linked
they'd be like oh that's just weird but
again and again so TV media in the
grocery store and again the reason why
we're talking about aliens as a bad
thing is because when you do the
research we understand aliens are uh
demons manifesting themselves as aliens
yeah yeah absolutely there's a really
great book by Joe Jordan I want to say
it's piercing the cosmic Veil I'm almost
finished with it but he is um a muon
director and he has collaborated with a
bunch of muon from around the world it's
like the mutual UFO Network I believe
pulling out my nerd knowledge um but he
has over 600 documented cases now of
people who have had horrible Terri
terrifying UFO encounters and just
calling on the name of Jesus has cast
them away so like what other proof do
you need if the name of Jesus you know
scares it away when he first he wasn't a
Christian when he started this journey
either he was like I believe in aliens
and he's going down the road of new age
and I can't remember his testimony but
somehow he became a Christian he started
looking through all these tapes of uh
abductees telling their stories and he
was like asking God God what what is it
I need to know what this is because I
don't understand if you created these
beings or what and God told him you've
already seen the answer what go through
the tapes again cuz they went through
all the tapes and him and his friend
were going through the tapes and next
thing I know they're seeing a testimony
that neither one of them remembered
watching but they watched all of them
and it's somebody saying yeah I was
pulled out of my bed into a spaceship
and I I just began to pray and sing
hymns and pray in the name of Jesus and
I was instantly thrown back into my bed
and they're like whoa wait a minute
because we've been to all these
conventions and people say say there's
no way to escape this thing you just
have to go through it so he started
going to continuing to go to all these
conventions and questioning that
question have you ever heard of this
where people are coming out of this
experience by praying in the name of
Jesus and they were like yeah we just
really didn't know what to think of it
yeah and actually in the book he says
that all the researchers have admitted
like yeah absolutely we have proof of
this but we can't really come forward
with that because it would ruin our
credibility exactly in the scientific
world like they don't want to cross the
spiritual barrier somehow I've had an
experience like that that I've shared on
the show it wasn't out of body though um
it was like I was walking down the
hallway towards my room and then all of
a sudden the the house started spinning
and I actually collapsed on the floor
and I didn't know what was happening I
was totally fine a moment before and I
said the name of Jesus three times and
just like that everything went away and
I was able to get up and and hadn't had
that problem ever again and so that just
having that experience was like wo just
um experiencing for myself the power of
the name of Jesus being able to say it
and things happen and everything stops
so same same here whenever that happened
to me when I was a teenager just pray in
the name of Jesus and it would go away
yeah yeah and it's like oh someone could
say oh maybe I had a medical episode or
whatever but it's like interesting you
say the name of Jesus and in that
instant that you say it everything goes
away I don't think that's how science
works
but um but yeah so anyway that to share
that it's like all right the next step
is out of body next step is having some
kind of spiritual thing it's like this
it happens to people yeah like if you
hadn't called The Name of Jesus what
would have happened exactly right like
where would that have progressed to
eventually you could yeah when you when
you the more you surrender to God Satan
attacks you more in hopes that you don't
understand spiritual warfare like okay
I'm going to attack them and maybe they
don't know to call on Jesus and and and
there might be people that don't and
they're getting having these attacks
sleep paralysis and all this stuff and
they they can't overcome because they
don't know how to fight the the
spiritual war
cuz we we are we're we're defenseless
against Satan unless we have his word
that's how Jesus himself Fought The
Temptations of the devil he didn't try
in his own physical strength or try to
outwit him or anything it's just like it
is written it is written it is written
every time speaking the word because it
is the sword amen that's right that's
good okay we're going to keep moving I
think I move on to a different show at
this point okay I don't know if any of
familiar with Toy Story yeah my husband
it's like his favorite so we rent this
one from the library it's the Toy Story
That Time Forgot so we have dinosaurs
and like Battle Bots and they come
together and the the toys that you're
familiar with Woody and all them come
and it's just a different world that
they see but it's interesting what they
say so I just wanted to show you a
couple clips from
[Music]
this now we know where they keep the
fossils
strangers from the unforgiving outlands
we have traveled far from the distant
Bon
tribe leave your offerings and be gone
are dinosaurs not welcome in our great
City wise
cleric fine fine have them made
presentable I find their lack of armor
disturbing so Y what I thought was
interesting here is the the little
creepy guy that comes out with the moon
and the stars he calls him the cleric
and so you know it's the religious
leader the guy that they're following
for you know obviously wisdom and all of
this things so I just included him to
show it's kind of like new Agy just that
that hint of it and also interesting
enough he's all concerned about their
armor which I just talking about like
the armor of God I'm like that's
interesting that they're all trying to
you know he's like they don't have armor
well he has a big staff with the stars
and moons and all these like kind of new
Agy things on it too and as a religious
leader he's definitely not looked upon
as like oh you're cool like we want to
hang out with you he was immediately
like oh so this is where the fossils are
kept you know yeah so like again
religion is portrayed as you know boring
that's true okay this next clip is where
it gets interesting you have to listen
carefully I could really get used to
this give us some musle you're a frer
aren't you life priore buildings
dinosaur carard whatever that thing's
meant to be what is it the Triassic
Tower of the dream Elders through which
distant beings convey Cosmic wisdom From
Another Dimension a at our house Bonnie
just yells across the room in a funny
voice I noticed that it seems like you
know Satan is so subtle so deceptive
that he really tells you the truth like
now they're even in the news they're not
even calling these things aliens like
when they go to these big hearings
they're like are they alien they're like
well I don't like to call them alien
because that puts them in a box or
they're nonhuman intelligences I'm like
okay so literally we're being told on
the news that we're we're communicating
with non-human intelligences like that's
literally demonic and right here he's
saying that we get wisdom from these
intelligent Cosmic beings or whatever
yeah I mean it does sound alien but he
said interdimensional too you know it's
offputting where did
God what thing did God use to meet with
Israelites the Ark of the Covenant the
temple before all of that and Moses had
to climb it to the mountain the mountain
he said that a mountain top of the M
beings terrestrial beings that's how
they uh talk to the people it's on this
mountain and on this so it's like for me
as a Christian reading the stories of
the Bible and then seeing this it's such
a counterfeit yeah and how do we know
what's truth and what's error you got to
test the spirits you got to know whether
they are speaking of God or of some
other spirit and just the themes and
what they're talking about and the
attitudes you know what spirit is there
yeah so I'm just curious are these Good
Guys bad guys who are they um in the end
they all end up turning good like they
they have to teach them that it's not
about like battling and they're Battle
Bots I guess so they like defeat like
rip toys apart so they're good guys that
get their knowledge from this creepy
interdimensional yeah Cosmic being it's
only like a 30 minute video I don't know
if there's more like in a series or
anything this is just what we found at
the library so I don't if there's
background to it I'm not sure but it
doesn't I don't think it really displays
them as good or bad it's like they're
you know they start off as bottle Bots
and by the end of it Woody and and Buzz
and their fashion teach them that you
know you're a toy and you're just acting
but you you should have find your
fulfillment in playing with children oh
instead of this yeah yeah it's
interesting putting the seed but at the
end there's like a kind of a a dance
episode like a dance scene where they're
all like happy and even the the weird
cleric is like doing a little jig but
like it's all still there so they might
have changed their mentality but they
still have their yeah the blending of
light and darkness it seems like yeah
okay we're just going to move on to our
next one has anyone heard of Paw Patrol
no PAW Patrol to my
[Music]
demise
look at your paws wao it's some kind of
Fireball well that makes sense you're a
fire pup I wonder what your power
is huh Chase Marshall up here hey how'd
you get over there so fast get over
with
great now the clumsy puff shoots
Fireballs out of his
paws cool I'm a wrecking
ball oh I can't believe I'm going to be
on the cover of May Magazine with our
amazing
meteor if I could just get a piece of
that meteor I'd get my super building
powers back and I'd make my own town to
be mayor of like that's ever going to
happen oh and maybe one more photo of me
like this
oops it's not like a meteor piece is
just going to fall right in front of me
like that meteor piece just did a meteor
[Music]
piece all right my super machine making
powers are
back now to Wy
bottom as a parent um how do you
navigate pure genuine imagination how do
you distinguish that or help a child
with that versus actually believing it
to be true cuz I can picture a kid he he
gets a rock he's like I'm King now and
he's running around with his siblings
and like the rock gave him that
Authority and that's just like Play It's
make believe it's fine it's innocent he
may not even have seen the show and he
comes up with that idea versus actually
believing like this rock gives me some
sort of power and he keeps in his pocket
wherever he goes or what have you how
would you navigate that as parents
honestly I I would say authentic
relationship with your children just
like God wants authentic relationship
with us when you have a good
relationship with your children you're
able to have those conversations it's
not like telling them one time hey
you're not going to get superpowers from
a stick or a rock they'll be like okay
well I'm still going to play with it I'm
still going to pretend but it's that
ongoing conversation so for instance for
this episode um these shows on PAW
Patrol my son was really into Paw Patrol
and those were the the ones I would let
him watch from the library it actually
helped me potty train him which I was
super thankful for he would only get to
watch a show if he you know okay did a
thing for the toilet so um he would
watch it and and when we got this show
he instantly was like whoa whoa what's
going on what's this he already has this
little bit of discernment coming and I'm
like what do you mean I was I'm not even
paying attention I'm like it's just Paw
Patrol and I look over and I'm like whoa
they're okay he's like yeah Mom they're
like superheroes and they get it all
from the rock I'm like hm do you ever
see that in the Bible he's like no I'm
like yeah that's interesting and then
after we kept watching was like I think
maybe we should not watch this he's like
yeah it kind of sounds like they're not
going to God like so we just turned it
off and of course he still likes say
they're Paw Patrol but he told me he's
like I can't watch that mom I'm like oh
good you know he's five but it doesn't
happen you know overnight you have to
have ongoing conversations and then they
develop that discernment for themselves
which when did you start having those
conversations like at two super early
super early yeah um I was really
protective of my children so we wouldn't
read any you know Disney or stories
about witches or you know even fairy
tales cuz a lot of that has that stuff
thrown in you don't catch it so we would
just read the Bible a lot kids stories
but different versions of Bible stories
V yeah yeah well a lot of books too the
old Veggie Tales back in good stuff
Bible based um yeah so as early on as
you can you know you never understand
how much their brain can comprehend as a
baby but a lot more I think than we know
even if they don't understand the words
it's like what you ingrained to them
early on sticks the hardest and the
Bible talks about you know once you've
given yourself into deception like
there's there comes a point where God
just gives you over to it oh yeah so you
know any any bit of deception as parents
we have to be really careful and what we
let our kids watch and what deception
we're letting into their hearts and
Minds because like you said from a young
age it really justes affect their belief
system and what they think is true I
know I'm not easy to live just put more
muscle into it Harold the kitties can't
concentrate with all this racket I'm not
making a racket Uncle mayor I'm reming
my super duper meteor power
robot watch
this ooh it's just as awesome as I
remembered actually awesomer I have
added a super amazing teleporter a tele
water a teleporter it can make stuff
disappear and reappear someplace else
[Music]
watch where' my mayor hat
go right
there that gives me a great naughty idea
let's go on a hat snatching spree so
this is just to show again you know how
they're using these Powers but uh KY
brought up earlier how there's always a
counterfeit for what God does so here
what they're doing with this rock is
they're now getting the power of
creation so he made this whole robot and
then putting the stone inside of it gave
it life wow so you know again just the
same kind of things going on and on but
I wanted to show the different things
that they were doing with the rock so
this next uh bit of cartoon that I
wanted to show comes as a little bit of
a shock because the other ones were all
secular whereas this one is Christian
based and I think made really well my
kids also love this show but again I
started seeing red flags so let's just
check it out and
see superbug have you heard of
superbug I've never watched it but I've
heard people talk about it this used to
play on TBN right TBN or CB yeah
Christian Broadcasting
Network
one yeah so this is really interesting
what I want you to just keep an eye out
for is uh what like where do they get
the Bible well just just keep an eye I
mean it took me almost 2 years to save
enough money for a telescope Joy how can
anyone expect me to take care of the
rest of the food dve
[Music]
money not I have to get my
T bear one another's burdens and so
fulfill the law of Christ wow okay okay
okay so aliens are demons and Demon
manifestations so technically the the
demons came and gave him the word of God
and then said I'm going to take you to
my realm to teach you about God what
yeah crazy though like it seems
completely unrelated but this is the
what's being like pushed right now in
media is like ufologists and all these
scientologists are saying the the new
information that we're getting from
these alien channelers and all this this
new tech and you know the what the
message that they're getting is that the
Bible's going to be replaced like we
have such new information about the
Bible it's like a rereading of the Bible
because of what we've now found through
science and channeling aliens well what
I've noticed is Satan can't say the
Bible's not true he can't say the
Bible's not true there's too much proof
it is so he takes all those stories and
twist them like oh yeah Moses did follow
a beam of light out of a Wilderness that
was a UFO he was following in the pillar
of fire the pillar of smoke well that
was the exhaust from a UFO aliens helped
them out of the Wilderness when Ezekiel
Saw a wheel within a wheel with eyes all
around the edge that was a UFO you know
these are primitive people describing
things that they didn't understand and
they just attributed to a God but it
really visitors from other worlds that's
the problem when you start stepping away
from the scriptures and don't interpret
scripture with other scriptures mean the
Bible with the Bible but when you start
adding your own interpretation you'll
never come to the truth yeah you know if
you know and believe that the Bible is a
source of Truth and we can see that
because because there's been times in uh
the Bible that that you can uh see how
it came true in history right there's an
actual connection between the Bible and
the physical world that we live in
prophe prophecies being fulfilled we
know the Bible is the word of God we
know that it is truth if you step away
from the source of Truth to find truth
you'll never find truth right just the
deception that's right there's plenty of
those everywhere the crazy thing with
this is we had watched this for many
seasons this is actually the clip show
is season five of Superbook and my son
one day was like why why are they
getting the Bible from a spaceship and
it never even clicked to me I was like
that does look like a spaceship like I
just thought it was some new tech you
know but yeah because the old one there
used this used to it started out as like
an anime and I like the art I love the
anime art and it's Christian but it used
to just be the Bible itself fly out of
the out of the drawer and open up
light they go into the Bible that sounds
way more you know closer to the truth
than this quick your
hel what's happening whatever it is he
won't lose it this time I do not like
this boosters
[Music]
BL what is that we don't know but look
get my back
[Music]
activ stabiliz
giz turn on surveillance campin we got
to report this thing and figure out what
it
[Applause]
[Music]
is what where' it go it just vanished in
thin air is exactly what aliens
do wait did he say exactly what Ali dude
yeah whoa no way super book a show about
the Bible is far from Biblical this is
unfortunate so kids when you see a blue
ball like denique did go after it see
what it is find out right that was the
biggest thing that alerted my red flags
was you know whatever you're seeing in
the sky chase after it like you have you
have to find out what it is that was the
whole mission in like the beginning of
the episode in the end was he was so
focused on this light and he had to know
what this light was which is the
complete opposite of what we're
instructed by God and we'll put the
Bible verse there of like he's saying
when when people say oh go here and look
at this or Christ is here do not go
don't figure it out you have to know
what it is no just don't even associate
yourself and they're here trying to
figure this out there's coming a time
when we have to live by thus sayeth the
Lord because there's going to be many
signs and wonders and it says that many
will fall from the faith or depart from
the faith giving heed to seducing
spirits and doctrines of demons and
that's coming from the lying signs and
wonders yeah which is we already seeing
though like this is seducing do uh
spirits and devils and seducing
doctrines yep all these movies and the
News telling you that aliens are real
and soon they're going to come I mean
they're going to manifest and they're
going to be on the news and they're
going to be saying hey we we can cure
all your problems Co can be gone and
cancer and all that and build your trust
and that's the signs and miracles that
are coming yeah then here they're
blending it with religion again so it's
not just science saying this is the
truth now it's religion saying it's okay
the Vatican is is is uh embracing this
idea of aliens as well so yeah it's
alarming so this next one I wanted to
show is actually part of the Bible story
of Phillip it's just interesting how
they depicted it happening I baptize you
in the name of the Father the Son and
the Holy
Spirit wow
[Music]
what's happening what is
that
[Music]
[Applause]
we have seen a miracle great is the
power of the Lord wait so that's Phillip
arising and that with with the Ethiopian
yeah so that takes place after he
baptizes the Ethiopian but what does it
say in the Bible it says he just
vanished appears it's not even like the
Bible isn't specific it it literally
says what happened he vanished and
they're like watching who he's going up
in a beam of light like like Jesus did
yeah you know and and God isn't AES with
the beam and everything the aliens have
come to get philli wo he's not
theatrical in this way and he's
purposeful about not being theatrical
because he doesn't want us to be so
easily deceived or follow him for the
wrong reasons so this is wow well that's
another thing with the whole Ancient
Aliens deception as they say you know
Enoch he was abducted by an alien Jesus
he ascended back to his mother's ship
Philip you he got transported by aliens
and he was a Christian production
basically embracing it yeah yeah that
must be the truth because it's
everywhere yeah I mean it looked just
just like that yeah like how similar I'm
thankful there wasn't a spaceship at the
top at least in super book but yeah like
it just identical to the idea of being
abducted here wow so that that was
definitely interesting because I didn't
expect those things to be in Superbook I
really like super book that's bum I do
too my kids love it but again like as
parents you just it it's about presence
you know you have to be present you have
to pay attention to what your kids are
watching and even if a show like we kind
of said earlier if a show seems good and
acceptable for your kids keep watching
it because you never know what it's
going to morph into as the seasons go or
what deceptions they're going to slip in
once it's past your safety net right
so so what do you guys think about does
this mean we should just like eliminate
all TV viewing all together because even
the good stuff is bad or or what do you
think I think you as a I'm not a parent
right now but I think that as a wise
parent it's Watch the episodes before
you watch it with your kid and that's a
Time investment but you know then you at
least know what you're showing them and
knowing how uh media and TV impacted me
as a kid and how you could just just
watch
one uh movie of Harry Potter like I did
and all of a sudden you know about it
you know there's magic it's not going to
leave your brain right and so just
watching it beforehand taking the time
to invest in your child and and you know
like if the if the show is continually
like oh there's like five episodes and
four of them are bad and one of them is
good I don't know I wouldn't waste my
time on that I'd be like find something
else that's more I don't know the very
least watch it together so when it comes
up you can you talk about it that that's
not said let's look what the Bible said
he vanished it's a good opportunity to
actually do some Bible study comparison
yeah and you know like like Wendy was
saying she's been teaching her kids this
from the beginning and now they're using
their discernment at 5 years old that's
right you know uh I know that in the
office our kids have this discernment
too and when my daughter sees something
she picks up on the follow your heart
let's break the rules and she'll just
kind of look at me like there it is like
you're right it's in everything um also
coming to the terms with there's not
going to be an an alternative for
everything that's right right so it it's
it's all right to teach your children
that it's okay to do without or to find
find fulfillment outside of media when
you think of all these um holidays like
Halloween and we're trying to replace it
with something else just don't do
anything you know on that day or treat
it like any other day and I think that
will that would help not just Guard from
from the messages that are in these
these films but it'll help them develop
as as people as balanced people of like
I'm okay like I'm not watching anything
and that's okay yeah there's definitely
a balance when you're a parent because
research shows that show like watching
TV and watching media isn't good for
development of their brain yeah that's
right so you have to be very careful
with how much you let them see
regardless of what the show is but then
you know eventually they're going to
grow up they're going to be exposed to
Media so you also don't want them to be
you know born as an adult into this
world of bombardment of media with no
discernment so I feel like as your
children grow you have to walk with them
and teach them how to use discernment
you know as they're mature enough to
accept it so and you're right about it
being a Time investment cuz there are
good things out there like little like
kids check that out little like kids our
newest and latest YouTube channel yeah
we need your support for that because we
believe in training up a child in the
way they should go and giving them
something that they can watch because a
lot of people are not throwing their TVs
out just because they know this
information they're they want to see
what can watch and we can't recommend
anything so we're going to make it
that's right do and another element of
course is prayer inviting God into your
home and asking him to reveal to you the
good things that are out there I
remember um scrolling through uh Roku
one time and I saw this free movie It's
called Acts of the Apostles and in the
bottom right hand corner I thought it
was timestamps but it was actually
verses they were going through the
verses of the Bible and it was the
narration was literally reading the
Bible so everything that was depicted
all the the dialogue most of the
dialogue cuz they had like they depicted
Luke um being a doctor and I was like I
was just clicking through and I found a
gem like that so the holy spirit is
there to utilize and if we just invite
him into our homes into our hearts he
will he will guide us amen well thank
you so much Wendy for showing us this
because we haven't picked up on this we
usually looking at trailers of new
things that are coming out but it's in
everything man so you got to be careful
guys even with the cute inant shows if
you guys like this video give it a
thumbs up it really helps get it out
into the algorithm so more people can
see this we want everyone to know that
they need to be Discerning of this stuff
and if you want to support this ministry
you can do so by going to Little Light
studios. TV there's a button up there it
says donate that really helps us out and
if you want to get something back check
out lightwear do shop we have some
awesome t-shirts where you can really
wear your witness they're great
conversation starters about spiritual
things you know somebody might just be
looking at your shirt Beauty for Ashes
what's that about great opportunity we
love you we thank you guys for all you
do all your support and we'll see you
next time on LED
live if you're looking for good
wholesome educational content for your
children subscribe to our new channel
little light
kids hey subscribe to Little Light
Studios noia Latina if you want to learn
Spanish a great way will be watching our
videos for
[Music]
practice